estamos en el paso fronterizo de palanca
en el lado de moldavia y aunque en estos
momentos no se ve mucha actividad ni
cruce de personas durante esta mañana
han salido decenas de ucranianos que
venían principalmente de la ciudad de
odessa después de que ayer hubiera
habido un bombardeo en una refinería
palanca se ha convertido en el centro de
recepción pero también de salida de
muchos ucranianos que quieren marcharse
a otros países de la región
especialmente rumanía porque es el más
cercano a quien palanca la gente ha
mostrado su solidaridad y ha dado
hospitalidad a muchos ucranianos pero
también empieza a tener miedo si la
guerra sigue avanzando es decir si las
tropas rusas siguen avanzando y llegarán
a tomar odessa por lo cerca que está de
esta frontera y también porque moldavia
al igual que ucrania ha sido una antigua
república soviética y podría repetirse o
esperan que la guerra se termine allí y
no pueda seguir avanzando las tropas
rusas a este país